[Musik]
sichtbar für die zivilbevölkerung sind
die ganzen katastropheneinsätze erst vor
kurzem mit meiner kompanie eingesetzt
auf compact 19 situation an der
tschechischen grenze
des weiteren ist es eine aufgabe der
pioniere bei katastrophen wie hochwasser
und mohn abhängen zu unterstützen
um die mobilität der truppe
sicherzustellen ist eine unserer
hauptaufgaben der brückenbau in diesem
rücken bauch sind wir spezialisiert
[Musik]
ein tag bei euch beitrag auch mit der
hat mir gereicht um zu sehen was alles
mittlerweile in unserer zeit zu ihren
aufgaben gehören großer respekt große
einer kleinen noch großer dank immerhin
die ersten an der grenze zur
grundsicherung
das ist etwas wirklich besonderes in der
macht